[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm der mcmanahan
this is sky news tonight the top story
more concern for the queen's health
buckingham palace announces that her
majesty will not attend tomorrow's state
opening of parliament the first time for
almost 60 years
we'll get all the latest reaction to
that story throughout the evening
also tonight victory day in russia but
no end in sight for the war in ukraine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
president putin fails to reveal his next
move as the advance of russian troops
halts and claims it is russia that is
under threat
in these days you are fighting for our
people in donbass for the safety of our
motherland russia
but in moscow as russia marks the defeat
of nazism the defense secretary here
claims putin and his subordinates are no
better
through the invasion of ukraine putin
his inner circle and his generals are
now mirroring fascism and tyranny of 77
years ago
this place is being shelled continuously
but still they come out
to bring in supplies of food water
and medicine
plus we'll have a special report from
donbass in the east where fighting and
bombing continues but so does the
mission to help those left behind
[Music]
a very good evening the president of
russia probably once thought that today
would look very different victory day is
the occasion on which russians celebrate
the defeat of nazism in europe but
victory for vladimir putin in ukraine is
still far from sight his forces have
stuttered to an embarrassing halt the
western world has closed ranks turning
russia into a pariah state and he will
no doubt be considering his next move
well coming up over the next hour we'll
have analysis of russia's progress or
lack of it in ukraine speak to a panel
of people who've been closely following
the situation and get the view from
moscow from one of its united nations
diplomats but first let's give you a
quick rundown of the day's other main
developments and it is the breaking news
that her majesty the queen will not
attend the state opening of parliament
tomorrow well our old commentator
alistair bruce joins me now and uh
alistair no doubt this will be a
decision that's been taken very
reluctantly and given that the lateness
of the announcement
i think it must be very aggravating for
the queen to have to face this mobility
issue that she has because for her the
constitutional duty of opening
parliament as sovereign at the start of
every session has always been very
important but they made many plans
to laws to try and make sure it was as
easy as possible for the queen to be
brought close to where she was to read
the speech but i imagine that she's
taken a decision with the advice of her
doctors tonight to not do it tomorrow
and she signed letters patents to enable
according to the best legal advice that
comes from the clerk the parliament's in
the lords for the prince of wales to
read it for her so in a way everything
is done perfectly normally but the queen
won't be with us
and what about uh previous occasions
that she has missed it
some time ago
that's right but i think what we should
remember is that every time parliament
is pro-rogued and we learned a lot about
that during this parliament or dissolved
the queen's speech is read for her by
commissioners a row of lords or those
representatives appointed by the queen
who then read her speech act so in
essence it's very rare
in history that monarchs have always
turned up free victoria in the latter
part of her reign hardly ever went to
parliament but the queen has been very
very strict on herself to try and attend
every opening of each session it's just
that on this occasion she is unable to
do so and it will be a real aggravation
for her i'm sure yes and it's these uh
episodic mobility issues that seem to be
the problem alistair
yes i think that you know my mother is a
similar age and
it's not always clear to her at the
start of each day what she's going to be
able to do and i think the queen
probably recognizes that this is a huge
role for anybody let alone her to go and
sit before the combined houses of lords
and commons in parliament watched by the
world and to read out an eight and a
half minute speech she's 96 and i dare
say that on the advice of her doctors
despite the fact that i expect she
wanted to go just the thought of having
to take that on is now removed from her
shoulders and after all that's what the
prince of wales can do for her and it's
what the structure and constitution
enables it'll be sad not to have her
presence but the crime will be there and
in essence it is in the name of the
crime that the prince of wales will do
it okay thanks for explaining aleister
good to talk to you alastair bruce our
royal commentator there well let's get
more on this now with our correspondent
laura bundock who joins us and uh laura
what precisely has buckingham palace
said
well they've issued a brief statement
explaining why this decision was taken
um and why it was taken at short notice
as well which i can now read to you it
says the queen continues to experience
episodic mobility problems and in
consultation with her doctors has
reluctantly decided that she will not
attend the state opening of parliament
tomorrow her majesty's request and with
the agreement of the relevant
authorities the prince of wales will
read the queen's speech on her majesty's
behalf with the duke of cambridge also
in attendance and of course as alistair
bruce was saying there this is the
queen's principal constitutional duty
and i think it will be reluctantly and
with great sadness that she has had to
take this decision uh not to attend the
state opening of parliament but i think
given her age given that she is 96 no
one um will criticize her for taking
this decision given the amount of uh
there's a spotlight that she's under and
the distances she has to walk as
alistair was saying even with cars being
moved so they can be closer to doors
there are steps where she has to walk up
to to take her seat and so no doubt
these were part of the problems but
we're told and we understand uh that her
majesty's carrying out other engagements
this week she spoke to the australian
prime minister today so no sign of her
duties slowing down virtually or by the
phone just in person these mobility
issues are obviously still troubling her
okay laura many thanks laura bundock
there
well now uh to politics and secure
stammer has said that he will resign as
the labour leader if police decide that
he broke lockdown rules and issue him
with a fixed penalty notice an
investigation is taking place into
whether sakir and others breached
restrictions when he had a beer and a
takeaway curry with labour activists in
durham in april last year
zakir says he's absolutely clear that no
rules were broken and this is a matter
of principle and honor for him i had to
isolate six times during covid
pulling me away from my work
and the things that i love
but i did it
because we followed the rules
the idea
that i would then casually break those
rules is wrong
and frankly i don't believe those
accusing me
believe it themselves
they are just trying to feed cynicism
to get the public to believe all
politicians are the same
i'm here to say that they're not
i believe in honor
integrity
and the principle
that those who make the laws
must follow them
northern ireland's first minister elect
has said the northern ireland protocol
must not be used to hold the province to
ransom shinfane's vice president
michelle o'neill was speaking after her
party became the largest in the northern
ireland assembly for the first time and
i should just warn you the footage of
her delivering a statement contains
flash photography
as democrats the dup but also the
british government must accept and
respect the democratic outcome of this
election
brinkmanship will not be tolerated where
the north of ireland becomes collateral
damage in a game of chicken with the
european commission
responsibility for finding solutions to
the protocol to make it smooth
implementation lie with boris johnson
and the eu
but make no mistake we and our business
community here will not be held to
ransom
okay let's return now to the victory day
parade through red square today the
usually ostentatious display while still
a spectacle was paired down this year
despite the blue skies over moscow a
military fly past was cancelled at the
last minute and one of president putin's
top generals general grasimov was
conspicuously absent there was no new
announcement from vladimir putin about
what he might do next in ukraine some
had expected perhaps the mobilization of
russia's reserve forces or a further
declaration about the scale of the
conflict instead president putin used
the occasion to blame the west for his
bloody war in ukraine our moscow
correspondent diana magnay was there and
has this report
shaking hands with the veterans
a salute from his defence minister
sergey
before taking to the podium to honor
russia's servicemen to stress russian
exceptionalism
and to deliver another rebuke to the
west who he says forced him to move into
ukraine
[Music]
as ever guarding the scene as the tanks
rolled through red square the
commander-in-chief looking on a blanket
on his lap and his face hard to read as
his troops yelled their support
in the absence of any actual victory on
the battleground this was really all
that vladimir putin could do claim the
moral high ground that this is all about
defending the motherland while showing
off his nuclear arsenal while he's at it
no flyover this year because of the rain
but the spectators still loved it the
message that russia here is blameless
vladimir putin has elevated the soviet
victory in world war ii to almost cult
status during his 22 years in power the
hard fought but eventual victory the
nazi threat motifs of his rhetoric now
around ukraine harking back to the
sacrifice of his soviet forebears
and in poland where russia's ambassador
tried to lay a wreath in memory
protesters threw red paint and chanted
fascist at him
a site which won't go down well back
home
russians in their millions march each
year to commemorate their fathers and
grandfathers vladimir putin leading the
way with a portrait of his father
huge crowds to honor the 27 million who
fought and died in what's known here as
the great patriotic war
in me
[Applause]
yeah stay a few years in russia and
you'll recognize the patriotic songs but
we were surprised to hear this one sung
in ukrainian by a man whose mother lives
outside kharkiv who prefer relations to
be as they were in soviet times
[Music]
his mother just wants to plant potatoes
he says keep ducks to eat them in winter
she just wants peace
but that might be a long time coming and
at what cost this time round
[Music]
and how will history judge the russian
people a few decades from now
and diana joins me now live so down as
you describe there plenty of pride honor
and patriotism in that speech but uh no
escalation
no when perhaps he doesn't have the
capabilities to escalate or the desire
to de-escalate but also remember that
victory day unless you have a victory to
declare is really a very important day
in the russian holiday
in the russian calendar and a day when
you just want to make the russian people
happy um so you were saying in the lead
into that piece that there were rumors
that he would decide to actually declare
war because at the moment it's just
called a special military operation and
mobilization might then be called i
don't think those things are off the
table but they're not really something
that he would likely do on victory day
he can do them any other time but not on
a day when he's trying to make people
happy and those mobilization rumors
haven't gone away by the way there are
still um reports from
various individuals that people have
been brought in uh that they've had to
submit um personal details in
expectation of a possible call-up so
those rumors are still there now
the other things you were talking about
uh you know the fact that there was no
flyover this year to be honest i've
covered about five or six of these
victory parades the weather was
incredibly turbulent today and they do
cancel uh the flyovers when there is an
expectation of rain and strong winds
like we had today
as to the absence or not of valerie
garasimov that is quite interesting but
he is not the key figure that you see at
these victory day parades in any case
that is always sergey shoigu there has
also been speculation about his health
over the past two and a half months but
there he was um in that limousine as he
also always is uh balancing his way at
the beginning of the parade uh saluting
his armed forces and he was very much
there valerie garasimov was rumored to
have been injured and that he'd actually
been deployed to donbass but in the days
since that rumor began he's also been
pictured alongside sergey shoigu on
state television so um you know we still
don't quite know why he wasn't there
today
um but he does seem to be back in russia
uh and certainly visible
okay diana magna in moscow thank you
very much
well meanwhile the british defense
secretary has said that vladimir putin
is dishonoring russian soldiers who
fought to defeat the nazis he also
called for russian soldiers and army
generals to face court martials over the
conflict in ukraine
through the invasion of ukraine putin
his inner circle and his generals are
now mirroring fascism and tyranny of 77
years ago
repeating the errors of the last
century's totalitarian regimes
they are showing the same disregard for
human lives national sovereignty and the
rules-based international system
the very system not least the united
nations charter itself that we conceive
together and for which we fought and
were victorious together in the hope of
saving future generations from the
scourge of war their unprovoked illegal
senseless and self-defeating invasion of
ukraine their attacks against innocent
civilians and their homes their
widespread atrocities
including the deliberate targeting of
women and children
they are all corrupt the memory of past
sacrifices and russia's once proud
global reputation
the response to this failure by the
russian forces on the ground in ukraine
has in itself been disgraceful display
of self-preservation doubling down on
failure anger dishonesty and
scapegoating
the behavior of the russian general
staff has shown that their own
self-preservation comes first
war crimes targeting civilians and the
casualty rates in their own battalion
tactical groups are all secondary
concerns
the truth is
that russia's general staff are failing
and they know it
ben wallace there well meanwhile russian
forces have continued their assaults on
the east of ukraine continuing to
destroy towns and villages people living
in the town of adv
sorry
on the front line are now relying on
volunteers for essential supplies as the
russians continue to advance from there
skies alex rossi sent this report
they are a lifeline to the people
trapped by the fighting
as the sound of war bangs in the
distance alexis safkovic and his
volunteers take essential supplies
wherever they are needed
25 30 000 so many really repeated
but some still stay here
this town of addie
has been fought over since 2014
and is smacking the path of putin's army
as russia tries to conquer the donbass
the first drop-off is an elderly man
whose family now live in russian
occupied territory
he is scared and all alone but like many
here is too frail to leave
strewn across the paths there are
fragments of bombs and rockets
the destruction has left this place
without power and running water
but the fighting doesn't stop them
loading the van with more supplies
this is the easton district now
their drive taking them to the edges of
this town
and even nearer the fighting
as more bags are handed over tetiana
tells me what the war has done to this
community
the delivery team go anywhere and
everywhere despite the danger
their next visit is even closer to the
front line and the handover is
nerve-wracking
where did the shell land
they don't enter this area so
it's okay
okay
well there's something coming in then
it's quite close but you can see how
dangerous
these deliveries are but this is on the
outskirts
uh there are still people here who can't
leave don't want to leave lots of
different reasons but
this place is being shelled continuously
but still they come out
to bring in supplies of food water
and medicine
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
when it feels safer they move from cover
and leave the area
but incredibly the deliveries continue
sometimes when it shells over you
and you can feel some some somewhere
closer
yeah there are some feeling when you
need to to lie not to
to keep your head down yeah yeah and
then the delivery stopped for that day
and you try again another day no we you
try one area yeah we wait we wait until
when this end is okay safer and continue
on the last stop we meet valentina and
her six grandchildren
in their childhood innocence they seem
oblivious to the war around them
every week civilians here are killed in
the fighting
alexi and his team know their work is
dangerous
but so too is living on the front line
and without him the suffering for many
of these people would be even worse
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine
and just let you know coming up at half
past nine tonight we'll have a special
programme with the stories of those
forced to flee the fighting in ukraine
and you're watching sky news tonight
coming up the view from the kremlin i'll
be speaking to dmitry polyansky a
russian envoy to the united nations
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm becky johnson a sky news midlands
correspondent based here in birmingham
[Music]
i remember seeing water pouring into
people's homes and businesses as rivers
burst their banks
[Music]
[Music]
now then vladimir putin used his victory
day speech today to accuse the west for
causing russia's invasion blaming nato
expansion for forcing russia into a
defensive war as he termed it with
ukraine well let's get more now on that
view from the kremlin i'm joined now by
dmitry polyansky first deputy permanent
representative of russia to the united
nations and very good evening to you mr
polyansky thank you very much everybody
for joining us may i start first of all
with that um characterization by
president putin in his victory day
speech and and i quote
he talks of nato creating an absolutely
unacceptable threat to us
causing russia he then said to launch a
preemptive strike in ukraine nobody in
the west recognizes that scenario
hello good evening first of all uh happy
victory day to everybody
i would like to congratulate everybody
who celebrates this day today
uh well you cited the words of my
president and i can tell you that it's
obvious right now that we are now having
the uh proxy war with nato so nato is
waging proxy war with russia not vice
versa but this that's the reality that
we face and uh
the documents that we discovered the
evidence that we discovered at the
beginning of our special military
operation
uh indicates with all clarity that uh
there were uh concrete plans to strike
on russia
from ukraine there were also concrete
planes to strike on donbass and the
documents of the ukrainian general staff
that we discovered indicate this so this
was kind of a preemptive strike from
russia we did it in full conformity with
article 13 51 of the un charter and we
notified the ian about it okay well as
the president put it it was a reaction
to a build up of armaments and special
advisors in ukraine but as the world
knows as you all know in russia the
build-up which started more than a year
ago around the borders of ukraine was by
russian forces
uh well it was it was a reply it was a
responsive act to the buildup of ukraine
near the line of contact in donbass
because there was about 100 000
ukrainian troops ready to launch an
attack in donbass and there were
constant shellings which have been
continuing for eight years which the
west ignored completely uh that's why of
course we had to be vigilant and we had
to be on our alert uh so of course this
move was a reply uh to what ukraine was
trying to build up at the border
and you know that we made a lot of
proposals to discuss the security
guarantees
to enter the negotiations with the u.s
and nato
it was absolutely rejected
the replies that we got were ridiculous
and they were not uh
talking about the the most important
things that we were
aiming aiming at
and so there was at some point of time
when ukraine was already preparing to
strike and then when the uh attack
started at uh
people's republics then we had not no
other way but to launch our strategy
okay we're still trying to continue to
understand that mindset and just on the
broad point about the nato threat
now nato has never attempted to attack
russia in more than 70 years going back
through those fraught relations with the
ussr the soviet union i noticed you've
got a small pin there with the hammer
and sickle on from that era why what is
that what is the russian understanding
of why nato would want to attack now it
doesn't it's a defensive organization
well it's not and it was quite clear
that nato is not a defensive
organization from the time of the war in
yugoslavia in the 1990s uh afghanistan
and there are a lot of other examples
nato countries were behind the uh
unconstitutional coup in ukraine in 2014
which triggered all the problems that
ukraine is having since then
so well you can't say that nato was
physically attacking russia nato is not
physically attacking russia right now
nato is just supplying uh weapons and
which kill our soldiers and will kill
which kills civilian population as well
but nato was of course behind all this
turmoil nato was sending advisors nato
was trying to embrace ukraine despite
the fact that
russia was warning repeatedly that it
would be crossing a red line so it would
it was doing uh everything uh
deliberately and provocatively so i
can't say that nato was idle and nato
was not promoting russia can i just get
uh your response finally to the british
defense secretary's statement today ben
wallace uh who talking about victory day
more or less said that uh today's
russian forces are dishonoring their
grandfathers
who fought the nazis and he said and i
quote in there that uh what's what
russian forces are doing now in ukraine
is mirroring fascism
well it's entirely uh
up to his conscience to say such a
blasphemous less famous things
i can only reply by saying that it's
absolutely disastrous and shameless what
the uk is doing right now forgetting
everything what we were fighting about
and i will only give you one one example
i will show you what what appeared today
at the official page of president
zilensky
here you can see it in instagram
and this is a
emblem
you see it like right now
i will i will make it
bigger
so that's the emblem do you know what it
is
it's
an it's an emblem of if a german
division
ss division in the second world war so
he published on this on the victory day
an emblem of fighter of uh right sector
with this emblem saying that this is a
symbol no don't interrupt me sir please
this is a symbol of fight against nazism
as he sees it this was deleted after
half an hour but of course we have a
copy of this and do you know that this
tottenham division was responsible for
murder of 100 britons in france
in at the beginning of the second world
war so it means that
the uk now is covering ukrainian
authorities which display uh nazi
symbols during the victory day
and these uh nazi symbols were used by
the same regiments that killed british
people isn't that a little bit strange
i'm really interrupting you because
you've heard this
you've had your saying we've run out of
time mr paul polyansky thank you very
much indeed to talk to you
and i should just say that uh those uh
images that were shown by mr polyansky
well we haven't been able to
independently verify them uh and you're
watching sky news a special on the war
in ukraine coming up i'll be talking to
several people who have been following
the conflict including the former prime
minister of finland
[Music]
[Music]
well as we've already been hearing
tonight there were no new announcements
from president vladimir putin at his
victory day speech about the war in
ukraine and it's left many people
wondering what vladimir putin's next
move in that war might be well i'm
joined now by joseph cirincione national
security expert and distinguished fellow
at the quincy institute and kira radhik
a ukrainian member of parliament and
leader of the opposition party golos
simin very good to talk to you and if i
could start with you first uh kira
radick because i i'm sure i hope you did
hear my last interview with one of the
russian representatives to the united
nations
and explaining their point of view on uh
president putin's speech that uh there
were parallels between defeating nazism
back in 1945 and what they are doing now
in ukraine your response
you know it was
i was very emotional when i was here
listening to what uh the previous
speaker was saying
they're basically saying ukraine was
wearing
lipstick ukraine was wearing a very
short uh skirt that's why we didn't have
any other way to act other than attack
and rape
this is exactly what they were saying
and this is exactly what russia is doing
and
it it could be funny that they are
living in such a a fairy tale world of
propaganda if there was not another
school that was bombarded recently in
the east of ukraine with
around 40 children
right now
harmed by this attack
you see right now
why all the peaceful negotiations or the
talks they are useless and they cannot
lead to any conclusion because the
position of russia in it is completely
out of this world it is uh
based on the total uh total propaganda
that they arrived and that they had all
the rights to invade my country that
they had the right to attack and kill
innocent people because they felt that
there was a threat they felt that nato
which is absolutely defensive
organization
was uh planning to attack them
another question is about a pro
rush pro-ukrainian coup that happened in
ukraine so can you imagine the imaginary
world a terrible world that they're
living in and they are acting and
fighting on it this is uh this is
absolutely uh terrifying when you're
thinking about it that the soldiers that
are coming to ukraine they are coming
with the same narratives we are coming
here to liberate you from from your
democracy we are coming here to fight
nato and kill nato on your land
did the school that a bomber did today
we had nato soldiers in it it's like
it's so unfair to my people and so crazy
that uh
russia is acting this way and it also
shows you that
no peaceful negotiations would ever be
possible the only way for us to
end this uh terrifying situation to end
this war is to win it to win it and push
them back to russia where they could do
whatever they want where they could
suffer where they could talk to each
other about this imaginary things so
it's it's it's completely insane well
thank you for setting the record
straight joseph sirencione give us your
analysis of president putin's speech
today in red square fairly short and
precious little then about the situation
in ukraine in terms of the military
operation and certainly no
indication of escalation
yes i thought the speech was very
revealing in what he didn't say he
didn't declare victory nor did he de
formally declare war which would have
allowed him to conscript larger numbers
of russian men into this this invading
force he doesn't appear to know what to
do at this point so what you heard was a
repetition of his basic themes they're
fighting nazism this is a continuation
of world war ii they're fighting the
aggressors of nato etc and but without
any plan for the future any anything
that he could tell the people what was
going to happen next and that's because
putin is in a bind he is losing this war
his new offensive after having lost the
battle for geve his battle for dunbas is
not going well he's basically static on
the front lines or in some sectors on
the retreat as the ukrainian forces are
pushing back and i believe this is just
going to get worse for putin as the
western supplied more advanced heavy
combat equipment comes into play the
artillery the drones the combat uh
fighting vehicles even new tanks come
into ukraine i believe the ukrainians
are turning the force of this war
against putin and he doesn't seem to
have a plan for what to do so that's why
i thought his speech was so somber so
bombastic but also so brief yeah keith
reddick i saw you nodding along with
that and you touched on it in your first
answer to me is this the only way this
war ends
even when russia is pushed out of all
ukrainian lands because there were talks
early on in the conflict which seemed to
indicate that perhaps
crimea might be ceded to russia parts of
the donbass is that now off the table
from the ukrainian point of view it's
you get out of ukraine all together and
then we can talk
yeah i totally agree with this get out
of ukraine and then we can talk
i totally agree with james that the
important point in putin's speech was
what he did not say
because
he was
talking again the propaganda statements
but he also did not say um beforehand
that he would attack ukraine he also did
not say that he would attack crimea but
he still did
so even though we know that russians are
losing right now we need to beware and
we need to continue on our plan
you know here in kiev we were very very
worried before the may 9s we
were expecting anything we were
expecting uh potential um nuclear attack
or the announcement of full-scale war or
something else but we knew that he could
do anything
the important point is that we should
not change our plan depending on what
putin is doing and our plan is uh all
the democratic countries are united
around ukraine we are getting additional
weapons every single day and we need the
most important weapons the air force
protection of our skies
we need the sanctions to be voted for
and start working we need to make sure
that russia does not find new markets
for its oil and we need to start working
on the next step which is embargo on
russian gas with all that russia will be
weakened out we will be fighting as hell
and i can promise you that we will be
pushing them back and we will make sure
that there is no invader on our land and
then when russia is weakened out when
they cannot continue their offense we'll
be living in the new democratic world
where countries like ukraine can develop
and countries like russia are pushed on
the sides of the history
joseph cyrus what might i saw you
nodding along with that um
what might that all mean though you know
a cornered we've discussed this many
times before but i cornered
president putin and pushed back
president putin now we know what we saw
in red square today as well as all those
military forces and personnel we saw
the ballistic missiles we've heard the
threat of nuclear action ill-defined at
the moment but we know what a mighty
arsenal russia has
mighty use them
yes he might and this is the great worry
that we have
kiera if i may call you that i'm a fan
of yours i follow you on twitter and i
saw that the other day you said any day
there's not a nuclear attack in ukraine
is a good day and i would have to agree
with that that is what you're worried
about
ironically as putin loses this war the
risk of nuclear escalation increases
that's because of the russian doctrine
of escalate to de-escalate if they are
losing a conventional
war with the west and they consider this
a war with the west there's a doctrine
that says they would use a nuclear
weapon to shock the west into retreat to
convince the west that they have to back
off so you have to be worried about that
i don't think it's likely but it's
possible and that's why i appreciate the
careful way that the biden
administration and the nato leaders are
aiding ukraine they're not being
provocative they're slowly increasing
the level of their aid they're not
attacking russia itself they're not
threatening russia with regime change
they're trying to prevent you uh russia
from doing anything hugely dangerous and
that means that in the end and i may
disagree with kira here you are going to
have to have a negotiated solution to
this okay this
is that but joseph we are running
outside so i just got to get this
question though but if
russia uses a nuclear weapon and i know
there are different ways and different
sizes they could use
doesn't the united states doesn't nato
have no other option then if that
happens than to attack russia with
nuclear weapons because if they've done
it once the next time it might be
heading for new york
yes but here's the power of the nato
alliance our conventional weapons are so
effective that we could conduct a very
strong conventional attack against for
example the airport or the facility that
launched a nuclear attack against
ukraine itself without resorting to
nuclear and i believe the biden
administration and the nato allies would
first seek to try to resolve the crisis
at that level without escalating it if
of course he uses a large nuclear weapon
against a nato target then all bets are
off okay thank you both very very much
indeed really good talking to you both
joseph serencione kira radick very good
to see you
thank you to uh continue with some of
those themes now because speaking at
another event today the british defense
secretary was asked about nato
membership for finland and sweden who
are not currently members both countries
have been considering membership of the
military alliance after russia's
invasion of ukraine asked whether their
edition would be provocative to russia
ben wallace said he didn't think so
saying that the expansion of nato is
just a consequence
of the russian aggression in ukraine
well i'm joined now by professor
alexander stoop former prime minister of
finland and a director now at the
european university institute very good
to talk to you professor shtube well
let's talk about that i mean first of
all how close now is finnish membership
of nato we see that the population are
very very keen now on joining
yeah definitely the latest opinion paul
came out today and it had 76
of the population in favor and 12
against and i guess you can compare that
to our eu referendum in
1994 which was 57.43
now how imminent did this well we expect
our president sally needs to announce on
thursday our intent to make the move the
official decision will take place on
sunday and then we will basically file
or show our intent to join nato together
with sweden next week on monday or
tuesday so really historic days ahead
can it be quite a fast track though i
mean i'm thinking how quickly then
does article 5 of nato membership that
doctrine of
an attack on one member is an attack on
them all and there has to be a response
how quickly does that apply if you're in
the waiting room so to speak
well i think ever since putin attacked
ukraine on the 24th of february the
leadership of both countries i've been
doing a lot of shuttle diplomas so you
saw the president of finland in
washington during the same week and the
prime minister sweden doing similar
types of moves so i think that we have
security assurances both implicit and
explicit and of course article 5 legally
speaking
happens once you join now i think
finland and sweden will be fast-tracked
members so it just basically depends on
how quickly the nato member states all
30 of them will be able to ratify our
application i expect us to be members uh
latest by the end of this year probably
a little bit earlier wow that really is
fast track but then what about this
issue of provocation you heard the
speech from president putin in red
square today railing against nato as it
is already configured talking about the
proxy war in ukraine the direct threat
to russian territory isn't there a
danger then that they do something
preemptive in finland before it gets
formally into nato
not really i mean you can never of
course count it out but we don't expect
conventional intimidation but we do
expect hybrid
um which basically basically means some
form of cyber or information attacks on
the cyber side when stalinski was
speaking at the finnish parliament a few
weeks back
the russians attacked the homepage of
our foreign minister defence minister at
the same time russian aircraft violated
finnish airspace on the information side
we'll see a lot of this information in
russia about finland and sweden in
finland and sweden about us but probably
more worryingly in the 30 nato member
states about the possible ramifications
of
us becoming members but to be honest i
think uh you know it's a foregone
conclusion putin and russia knows that
and can i ask you because you know we've
talked before about how well
the the finnish and the finnish
leadership know the mind or used to know
the mind certainly of president putin
and those links between your president
and president putin um
do you think putin really believes
that stuff about nazism in ukraine and
you know pictures of
death's head from the the ss i mean that
they're re-fighting the second world war
is that to to mobilize the army to to
keep morale up within russia itself
or does he really believe it in which
case we've got a problem haven't we
well
you know you have to understand one
thing that in the russian language there
are two words for truth and one of them
is the legendary product and problem
actually means tactical truths and that
means that whoever you're talking to
knows that you're lying but because
you're doing it for the common good in
this particular case russia you sort of
accept it so you know i think there is
an element of yes he believes it but
then the other element is also
propaganda but the problem of course
here is that you know repetition is the
mother of all knowledge so the more
often you repeat it the more you start
believing it yourself and this whole
narrative of denazification
and you know i've gotten it in messages
from uh quite reliable russian sources
in the past few weeks so the language is
certainly out there i'm afraid
just lastly i mean is diplomacy dead
at the moment we saw those talks flurry
of talks various world leaders getting
involved in the early stages of the war
doesn't seem to be happening now and as
we heard from ukraine they say right the
only way this ends is we eject the
russians from our territory
yeah i think diplomacy at the moment is
dormant so if you compare this to the
war in georgia in 2008 i was foreign
minister finland and chairman of the
osce and brokered sees the ceasefire on
the ground in belize and in moscow in
five days
this war is now into i think its 75th
day the finnish winter war lasted 105
days i'm afraid we're in this for the
long haul because there is very very
little space for any form of a ceasefire
because the two parties are so far apart
and understandably so professor schtube
always good to get your analysis thank
you so much for joining us once again on
sky news tonight
alexander stoop there uh former prime
minister of finland and that's nearly it
for this special program on the war in
ukraine but we're going to leave you
with a a positive story yes from ukraine
a rarity of course among all the
brutality and tragedy
mark austin has been to tell a story of
an animal shelter caught up in the
fighting north of kiev in hostimel
when the war came to hostimel it was
intense and brutal and grim and many
people died
most of those who could fled the horror
unleashed by the russians here
but max skripnik was not one of them
because in his words he had 600 lives to
protect the dogs he cares for at the
shelter he runs here
he wanted to make sure they were watered
and fed and not abandoned so he stayed
even as the shells came in
so max this shell landed while you were
here and you were right in the middle of
a battle then yes we even have a chance
to see and to even calculate how many
missiles was on on the ear from
different sites and we even saw these
missiles and it was not dozens it was
hundreds of missiles per day
he stayed for much of the russian
occupation of this village the shelter
owner asia sapinska stayed through all
of it the ukrainian people fulfilled
their everyday job and our everyday job
to provide a good life for our animals
and
i hope that we did this job
so frightened with the dogs during the
height of the raging battles they dug
their own holes to escape down when the
noise was too much
some of his animals died the dogs here
died
from the bombarding
or from the heartbreak
when he died
we continue to find the dyed animals
continue to find
he's found a use for the ammunition
boxes left by the russian occupiers who
he persuaded to allow food and a
generator to be brought in to keep the
place going
one six-week-old puppy was born during
the fighting here
she survived
max's priority now is to find homes for
puppies like this and reunite other dogs
with owners who fled
in the midst of war these are people
risking their lives to protect animals
in need it is their duty they say and no
one will persuade them otherwise
mark austin sky news hostimel
and that is it for this war in ukraine
special coming up in the next hour the
latest on her majesty the queen who will
not attend the state opening of
parliament
[Music]
[Music]
you